RICHARD MADDEN
Hey, everyone! We're from the cast of
Marvel Studios' Eternals...
BRIAN TYREE HENRY
...and our Marvel knowledge is about to be
tested with a little game of
True or False: Marvel Edition.
BRIAN TYREE HENRY
That's true.
GEMMA CHAN
It's false.
KUMAIL NANJIANI
No! It's this.
BRIAN TYREE HENRY
It's false?
KUMAIL NANJIANI
[Laughing]
KINGO [in sign language]
Nice move.
MAKKARI [in sign language]
You, too.
BRIAN TYREE HENRY
This is incredibly specific.
GEMMA CHAN
False...
BRIAN TYREE HENRY
Oh!
- Yes!
BRIAN TYREE HENRY
False!
RICHARD MADDEN
Ah! I'm not good at left and right.
KINGO
That explains so much.
KUMAIL NANJIANI
I hope it's not, so I'm gonna say false.
BRIAN TYREE HENRY
[Laughing] It's true!
RICHARD MADDEN
I'm going with Gemma.
SPRITE
It's true, buddy.
EVERYONE
Oh!
CLINT BARTON
What? You didn't see that coming?
BRIAN TYREE HENRY
All the J.A.R.V.I.S.'s I know,
that's what it stands for.
RICHARD MADDEN
I'm gonna say false.
KUMAIL NANJIANI
Secret nerd, Lauren.
True!
- I'm gonna say true.
- They were pals.
BRIAN TYREE HENRY
That's a hard false.
KUMAIL NANJIANI
Ah!
IKARIS
Ouch.
KUMAIL NANJIANI
No. You know what, they're wrong.
I'm right.
BRIAN TYREE HENRY
Unbelievable.
GEMMA CHAN
[Laughing]
RICHARD MADDEN
Next question.
GEMMA CHAN
I'm going with true.
KUMAIL NANJIANI
Yup, all of that is true.
KINGO
Hey, that one was mine! Oh, nevermind.
SALMA HAYEK
And they're gonna love it!
RICHARD MADDEN
True. I'm gonna say true.